[Musique]
on retrouve avec grand bonheur ce soir
nos amis communistes jean martin aussant
et jean luc landry messieurs bonsoir
bonsoir
bonjour joli jeu commence avec vous vous
en pensez quoi de ce passeport vaccinale
de l' annonce d'aujourd'hui à qui
s'adresse à partir de quand qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ce qui est annoncé
100% d'accord et je trouve aussi que le
gouvernement
le fait au bon moment souvent l'on a eu
un ministère je l'appelle le ministère
de la lenteur
cette fois ci c'est moi qu'il l'appelle
comme ça c'est le ministère de la santé
a pas ce qu'on attend toujours l à la
santé au québec mais cette fois si vous
avez un on est on est à la rentrée donc
c'est le bon moment on parle de deux de
l'incarner de mettre en place au début
de sept ans et deux semaines alors on a
trois semaines au total de s'adapter je
trouve que c'est la présentation est
bonne ça va ouvrir l'économie ça nous
permet enfin commence à bouger et de
reprendre une bonne partie de nos
activités je le trouve mentionné un
dernier point si le côté positif de
cette chose là c'est que jusqu'ici on
est toujours avec le bâton mais sais pas
si c'est une carotte parce que cible à
l'ouest et à l'est les gens qui m'ont à
6 ans au vaccin peut-être qu'il y en a
plusieurs là dedans qui vont changer
d'idée en dix ans mais j'aimerais bien
ça le restera si donc ce que j'entends
de votre part c'est que sur le plan
économique les commerçants vont gagner
des clients avec le passeport vaccinale
plutôt que d'en perdre jean martin vous
en pensez quoi mais je commence bien la
saison tout à fait d'accord avec le
passeport et jean-luc moi je cours
partout un peu
un espèce de contrat social vous savez
quand on a instauré le système des
routes et des voitures là on a établi
des permis de conduire on a fait des
feux rouges même quand il n'y a personne
qui est bien d'autres bars et c'était
une petite réduction des libertés
individuelles peut-être mais dans
l'intérêt collectif pour que les choses
aillent mieux et je trouve que ça ça
fait partie du contrat social en finir
enfin avec cette pandémie loeb c'est pas
un gros effort en bowling sks que pas
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas dû annoncer
des allègements en même temps c'est à
dire dès lors qu'un passeport vaccinale
que tout le monde est vaccinée dans le
restaurant dans le bas dans le bar ou
dans jim dans d'autres types d'activités
jean luc est ce qu'on devrait pas lever
toutes les restrictions notamment sur la
distanciation ou sur les capacités à
l'intérieur des lieux publics visés pas
vraiment parce que vous pouvez même si
vous êtes battu limoux puis là-bas il
donner à quelqu'un dos et puis cette
personne à son jeu restaurant s'en va
ailleurs et le donne à des gens qui
n'ont pas vécu les sons vont pouvoir
faire ça quand la plupart des gens sont
vaccinés et pour revenir à ce que jean
martel vient dire si tout le monde
faisait partie dû à l'iréo contrat
social on pourrait régler le problème
des vaccins direction assez rapidement
le ministre dit denise dubé jean marc
terre a dit aujourd'hui que le passeport
vaccinale n'est pas envisagée par
exemple pour avoir droit de revenir au
bureau donc on veut pas aller jusque là
on recommande encore sans doute obliger
le télétravail en ce moment est-ce qu'on
devrait aller plus loin sur le retour au
bureau est ce qu'on devrait aller
jusqu'à imposer une forme de vaccination
obligatoire finalement pour revenir dans
les tours à bureaux dans des bureaux en
général je dirais que ça dépend des
espaces de travail il ya des comme chez
nous si je donne l'exemple de notre
bureau chez nous on a tous des bureaux à
s'est séparé et distant donc c'est
peut-être moins propice à une
propagation de
risques dans les endroits aussi beaucoup
plus
rapproché d'un travers l'autre mais
comme le dit le ministre appartient
chaque employeur de le décider encore là
on espère que les empereurs votre
responsable dans la proportion de ceux
qui travaillent à la maison ceux qui
travaillent au bureau directement alors
je mentionne que je l'aimerais que 18
joueurs nationaux oui j'aimerais que les
employeurs au moins exigent que ceux qui
ne veulent pas ou ne sont pas vaccinés
le dise bonjour lamic mes confrères me
disent qu'ils ne sont pas vaccinés et
j'en fais plus attention parce que je
peux donner mes petits enfants qui vont
à l'école qui m'ont donné à d'autres ok
je vous mentionne que la vaccination
obligatoire commence à s'étendre aux
états unis en plusieurs endroits la
colombie britannique a annoncé
aujourd'hui une carte vaccinale pour les
événements sportifs
les concerts les spectacles notamment on
change de sujet monsieur je vous emmène
sur l'enjeu du coût de la vie et du coup
des propriétés ses dixième jour de la
campagne électorale fédérale les
libéraux aujourd'hui on dit qu'il
voulait faciliter l'accès à la propriété
en doublant le crédit pour les premiers
acheteurs en permettant une mise de
fonds de 5 % le npd a proposé dans les
derniers jours des hypothèques sur 30
ans les conservateurs des termes de 7 à
10 ans jean martin est ce que ces
mesures sont bonnes ou au contraire ça
peut alimenter dans les faits davantage
le surendettement des ménages
moi je pense que dans le contexte de
pénurie de logement ou de la flambée des
prix de l'immobilier c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup plus propice en économie
je pense
2d l'offre que de la demande quand on
est le demandons simplement le moyen ou
locataires aux futurs acheteurs de payer
plus cher pour ce qu'ils veulent acheter
donc sylvander qui en bénéficient ou le
locateur donc si on était plutôt la
construction de nouvelles unités donc du
côté de l'offre s'est créé un effet un
petit peu apaisant sur la flambée des
prix et ce serait pas mal plus efficace
dans ce qu'on cherche l'appui en plus
qu'un des objectifs de tout ça c'est
l'accessibilité au logement ou à la
propriété donc il faut travailler
beaucoup plus sur l'offre que sur la
demande je pense parce que la flambée
des prix sera pas du tout réduite sont
encourage tout le monde à avoir plus de
moyens acheté une maison il déroute
propose par exemple qu'on construise un
million quatre cent mille logements au
cours des quatre prochaines années les
conservateurs ont proposé un million de
logements supplémentaires
jean-luc là dessus
les j'ai lu le programme libéral
les chiffres concordent pas là
non mais c'est justement ça va coûter
bien plus cher qu'un milliard de dollars
pour le système de subvention de local
de location avec option d'achat cela
s'est il ya quelqu'un qui sait pas
qu'elle publie quelque part mais une
option sur une maison de 500 mille
dollars dans combien ça vaut une option
de cinq ans une option de cinq cent
mille dollars
ça vous moins 100000 dollars alors le
fédéral est pas capable de compenser ça
il ya personne qui va donner ses options
il ya plusieurs choses dans les
programmes qui sont entre est un espèce
de ramare si j'ai lu ce découpage est
vraiment aussi de choses pour être
populaire mais si on a besoin ce dont on
a besoin ici linverse comme jean marc
c'est indigne augmenter l'offre et
ralentir la demande en ce moment on
permet aux gens d'acheter avec 5% de
mises de fonds sont le seul levier
financier de grenier fois les banques
ont même pas le droit d'avoir des nervis
financier aussi l'exode alors quand même
les policiers sont neuf font pas preuve
de responsabilité dans ce col web et
c'est ça depuis dix jours on nous martin
de toutes sortes de noms sur
l'immobilier parce que c'est un sujet à
la mode quand même là les conservateurs
et le npd plus libéraux aussi
aujourd'hui veulent stopper la
spéculation étrangères par exemple en
interdisant les libéraux aujourd'hui
pendant deux ans la chatte propriété au
canada par des investisseurs étrangers
est ce que c'est une bonne chose à faire
jean martin mais moi je pense qu'il faut
pas oublier qu'une maison c'est d'abord
et avant tout un endroit où vivre ça ne
va pas être un instrument financier
spéculation puis c'est devenue soeur
dans le marché actuel et quant au fait
de limiter l'achat ou quand on parle des
acheteurs étrangers c'est souvent des
gens qui veule ou parfois peut-être pas
dans tous les cas mais des gens qu'ils
occupent même pas ce logement là et qui
spéculent que les prix vont monter assez
pour faire une pièce avec ça dans
quelques temps et moi je péterais toutes
taxes non seulement aux étrangers mais
même aux locaux qui veulent acheter sans
occuper juste pour spéculer voilà ce que
comme je le disais une maison le niveau
premier de la pyramide de maslow c'est
pas le niveau supérieur ou un samu où on
s'amuse et on se valorisent et plus
riches que l'autre c'est vraiment un
endroit où vivre une maison dont il faut
cesser les spéculations loeb tous les
moyens sont bons je prends un petit mot
sur la banque du canada dont le mandat
pourrait changer un peu mais pourrait
aussi ne pas changer c'est à dire la
banque du canada pour objectif d'avoir
une cible d'inflation de 1 à 3% 2 %
comme cible principale là on est en
train de réfléchir à ce moment à sa
mission et quand on a demandé à monsieur
trudeau ce qu'il en pensait de la
politique monétaire et dira je m'occupe
pas de ça ce qui me préoccupe c'est les
canadiens hélas les conservateurs lui
ont redit balas et si vous vous occupez
pas de ça c'est que vous ne vous
intéressez pas à l'inflation et au coût
de la vie vous en pensez-quoi jean-luc
de sa
première en tant mieux
parce que la banque du canada doit
rester indépendante et le gouvernement
ça va pas de lui tendre les bras d'une
façon blonde et jusqu'ici ça bien été
d'avoir une banque centrale indépendante
en fait dans la plupart des pays alors
ça c'est la première main tenant
monsieur trudeau
je pense le chytride ou sait pas compter
alors aussi bien pour trop s'occuper
d'autre chose on a pu affirmer encore
une fois les dépenses actuelles du
gouvernement libéral et celle promise ça
fait pas beaucoup de chance ok mais chez
eux sans vous en parle mais je pense que
c'était une formule malheureuse que le
premier ministre ne répèterait pas ayant
vu ce que ce que commencent à résonner
dans les airs et de ceux qui l'écoutent
elle parce qu'en fait c'est un message
qui ressemble un petit peu et celui des
etats-unis parce que on a dit le beau la
réserve fédérale a dit que le plein
emploi et est maintenant une priorité
plus grande que l'inflation limitée et
c'est peut-être plus que le terminus
voulait dire que le plein emploi pour la
classe moyenne que les gens un boulot
c'était dans le court terme plus
important je peux pas le défendre mais
c'était plus un faudrait que de passer à
l'inflation donc si je pense que c'est
une phrase malheureuse parce que c'est
évident que le premier ministre doit
s'intéresser à ce qui se passe sur le
plan de l'inflation pour son peuple
excellent jean martin aussant qui défend
bien premier ministre hugo se doit merci
beaucoup jean martin on va se retrouver
mardi prochain merci jean luc hardy pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici r d